en esta ocasión vamos a seguir
trabajando con sistemas de ecuaciones
pero esta vez quiero ver sistemas de
ecuaciones consistentes e inconsistentes
es decir los sistemas de ecuaciones que
no tengan solución o en dado caso que
tengan una infinidad de soluciones pero
antes de eso vamos a ver un sistema
mucho más sencillo y consistente así que
veamos este sistema tengo 3 x 4 james y
esto lo voy a hacer igual a 13 y por
otra parte me voy a tomar ye igual a
menos 3 x menos bien menos 3 x menos y
bueno lo quiero resolver por el método
de suma y resta o de eliminación y por
lo tanto para ello lo que voy a hacer es
copiar la primera ecuación tal cual es
la voy a dejar tal cual y la voy a poner
de este lado 3 x menos 4 james esto es
igual a 3 cm y por otra parte de la
segunda ecuación quiero que te des
cuenta que no tiene los términos
reducidos por lo tanto para reducir
términos todo lo que tenga que ver con
gem de un nuevo de la ecuación lo que
voy a hacer es restar 10 de ambos lados
de la ecuación y por lo tanto vamos a
restar y aquí esto no va a quedar 0 y
del otro lado va a quedar menos 3
- 210 y bueno ya tengo la otra ocasión y
fíjate qué bueno aquí tengo menos 3x
mientras que acá arriba tengo 3x esto me
va a servir bastante para usar el método
de suma y resta pero bueno vamos a
copiar esta ecuación aquí abajo menos 3
x menos 2 james esto igual a cero esto
igual a cero y apliquemos el método de
suma resta porque ya nos dimos cuenta de
que podemos eliminar la equis de una
manera muy rápida por lo tanto vamos a
hacer el método de suma resta del lado
izquierdo y del lado derecho y de la
izquierda que me va a quedar déjame
poner aquí una línea que es la que me
falta y entonces me queda 3x menos 3 x
estos dos se van se eliminan se cancelan
y después me quedan menos 4 james menos
2 james estos menos 6 james y por otra
parte tengo 13 013 más ceros 13 y bueno
ahora para despejar el valor de james
voy a discutir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre menos seis entre menos
seis entre menos seis y por lo tanto me
queda que el valor de y es igual a 13
sextos negativo o dicho otra manera a
menos 13 sextos muy bien este es el
valor de james de mi solución y ahora
también saca el valor de x no lo olvides
y para eso lo que voy a hacer es agarrar
la primera ecuación y voy a sustituir el
valor de y en la primera ecuación
entonces me queda 3 x 4 pero llévale
menos 13 sextos esto es igual a 3 y
bueno vamos a despejar la x entonces
menos x menos me da más y aquí puedo
sacar mitad la mitad de 4 estos y la
mitad de 6 es 3 esto es mucho más fácil
de multiplicarlo entonces me queda 3x
más 2 por 13 es 26 26 tercios esto es
igual a 3 sin embargo al 13 lo vamos a
ver de una vez en tercios para que se
pueda simplificar fácilmente con este 26
tercios 13 es lo mismo que 39 tercios 39
tercios y ahora sí voy a restar 26
tercios de ambos lados de la ecuación
para que de esta manera pueda despejar
mucho más rápido x entonces menos 26
tercios de este lado y menos 26 tercios
de este otro y entonces que me va a
quedar del lado izquierdo pues solamente
me queda 3x porque estos dos se cancelan
mientras que el lado derecho a 39
tercios menos 26 tercios
es lo mismo que 13 tercios
y ahora voy a dividir todo entre 3 para
que abras y obtenga el valor de x voy a
dividir todo entre 3 o multiplicado por
un tercio entonces mejor vamos a
multiplicarlo por un tercio
multiplicando por un tercio estos 2
evans me queda que x es igual a un
tercio por 13 tercios es lo mismo que 13
novenos muy bien ya tengo el valor de x
es decir que la solución de este sistema
de ecuaciones es x igual a 13 novenos ye
igual a menos 13 sextos y por lo tanto
estamos hablando el sistema consistente
porque tiene una única solución este
sistema de ecuaciones es un sistema
consistente porque el punto de
intersección de estas dos rectas es el
punto tres novenos como a menos 13
sextos vamos a apuntarlo sistema
consistente consistente muy bien y ya
que tengo que este sistema consistente
pues podremos imaginarnos un sistema que
no sea consistente un sistema
inconsistente y cómo se vería entonces
vamos a tomar otro ejemplo para ver e
ilustrar a qué me refiero imagínense que
yo me tomo la ecuación 5 x menos 4 james
a uno y me voy a tomar otra ecuación la
ecuación menos 10 x más 8 james y esto
lo voy a hacer igual a menos 30 y bueno
yo quiero resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones y lo quiero resolver por el
método de eliminación o de suma y resta
y bueno para esto tengo que elegir una
de las variables a la cual la voy a
eliminar y voy a decir que quiero
eliminar a la equis y por lo tanto voy a
multiplicar la primera actuación por 2
de tal manera que me queda 10 x menos 8
y esto es igual a 22 por 12 y date
cuenta que ya con esto eliminamos el x
porque me queda menos 10 x 10 x y
entonces vamos a sumar lo de una vez
entonces sumemos esta parte de la
ecuación y me queda 0 x 0 x del otro
lado tengo 0 y también y después tengo
que esto es igual a menos 30 más 2 que
es menos 28 pero 0 x 0 y el mismo que 0
y entonces me queda la igualdad 0 igual
a menos 28 y aquí hay algo raro te das
cuenta que pasó aquí porque al final
cuando ceros igual a menos 28 pues nunca
nunca 0 es igual a menos 28
y cuando nos pasan estas cosas bizarras
esto quiere decir que no tenemos
solución y este es un clásico ejemplo de
un sistema inconsistente cuando llegamos
a algo que es bastante absurdo cero
igual a menos 28 algo que no tiene
sentido estamos hablando de un par de
ecuaciones con un sistema de ecuaciones
que no tiene solución y cuando pasa esto
es uno de los ejemplos de un sistema
inconsistente cuando no tenemos solución
y por qué pasó esto suena muy raro lo
que está pasando no pues vamos a
intentar graficar estas rectas para que
entiendas un poco mejor lo que está
pasando y por qué no tenemos solución
así que déjame darle la primera ecuación
5x menos 4 y igual a 1 y vamos a ponerlo
en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
para que la podamos graficar y para esto
pues lo que hay que hacer es despejar
ayer por lo tanto voy a restar 5x de
ambos lados de la ecuación de tal manera
que me quedan menos 4 y james es igual a
menos 5 x más 1 y ahora voy a dividir
todo entre menos 4 para que ahora sí me
quede el valor de despejado vamos
y todo entre -4 todo entre -4 y por lo
tanto que me quede aquí es igual a menos
cinco cuartos menos un cuarto perfecto
ya tengo la primera recta en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen pues vamos
a hacer lo mismo con la segunda ecuación
vamos a tomarnos la segunda ecuación y
vamos a despejar también a la ye para
que así obtengamos una recta de la forma
pendiente orden al origen y la podamos
graficar y manu lo que voy a hacer es
despejar al agen por lo tanto voy a
pasar el 10 x del otro lado con signo
contrario me queda 10 x menos 30 y
después dividiendo todo entre 8 me va a
quedar o esperaría borrar o me va a
quedar 5 cuartos de x menos y 30 entre 8
es lo mismo que 15 entre 4 menos quince
cuartos los asesinos son reduciendo las
fracciones 10 entre ocho son cinco
cuartos 30 entre ocho son menos cinco
cuartos espera por aquí debe de haber
algo mal por eso te decía que nuestro
nada que había algo raro es que aquí es
más claro claro claro menos entre menos
me da más cuando dividió todo entre
menos 4 me quedan menos 5 entre menos 4
lo cual es positivo y después 1 entre
menos 4 lo cual es menos un cuarto
ya tengo aquí a mis dos rectas en su
forma pendiente ordenar el origen y
ahora vamos a graficar las pero lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta
antes de graficar las es que tenemos la
misma pendiente tenemos dos rectas con
la misma pendiente qué significa eso
bueno seguramente ya tienes una idea o
ya recordaste qué significa eso pero de
todas maneras vamos a graficar las para
que te des cuenta de qué es lo que está
pasando
la primera corta en menos un cuarto es
decir justo aquí y como tenemos una
pendiente de cinco cuartos por cada
cuatro que avancemos vamos a subir cinco
entonces pasamos por aquí y entonces
también para abajo y se forma una recta
muy parecida a ésta mientras que la otra
recta como se va a ver bueno corta en
menos quince cuartos menos quince
cuartos es mucho más abajo que menos un
cuarto por lo tanto lo voy a poner esto
es como si divido 15 entre 4 me da como
tres puntos 75 es menos 3.75 por lo
tanto está mucho más abajo que el menos
un cuarto y por lo tanto que me quede
vamos a poner que este es el menos 3.75
el menos quince cuartos y entonces voy a
una pendiente de cinco cuartos quiere
decir lo mismo que por cada cuatro que
yo avance la derecha entonces voy a
sufrir cinco por cada cuatro yo voy a
subir cinco y entonces obtenemos una
recta muy parecida a esta perfecto ya
tengo aquí a otra recta a la recta que
es la representación gráfica de mi
segunda ecuación y lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que estas dos rectas son
paralelas como tienen la misma pendiente
son dos rectas paralelas por lo tanto
estas rectas nunca se van a interceptar
recuerda que es dos rectas paralelas
nunca se intersectan es decir este
sistema inconsistente no tenía solución
porque realmente estamos hablando de dos
rectas que son paralelas pero las rectas
paralelas nunca se intersectan por lo
tanto nunca vamos a encontrar un punto
de intersección entre ellas esta recta
se de graficar esta ecuación que tengo
en blanco mientras que esta otra recta
de graficar esta ecuación que tengo de
amarillo y por lo tanto como son rectas
paralelas entonces no existe ningún
punto en común no hay un ningún punto en
común y por lo tanto no hay un punto de
intersección pero bueno vamos a agarrar
nosotros
ejemplo de estos sistemas raros que
tenemos aquí 4 x 50 y 3 x es igual a 6
10 + 4.5 y bueno de hecho no espérame
espérame porque estas ecuaciones que
tengo aquí son muy parecidas a las
ecuaciones que tengo en el ejemplo
anterior pero ver todas las posibles
opciones que tengamos de sistemas de
ecuaciones que no sean consistentes así
que mejor déjeme tomarme este 3x menos 7
james esto va a ser igual a 1 y por otra
parte me voy a tomar la ecuación a 6x
déjame ponerlo aquí menos 6 x más 14
james esto es igual a menos 2 muy bien
ya tengo aquí un sistema de ecuaciones y
si yo quisiera resolver por su me restan
pues entonces lo que hay que hacer es
primero recuerdan elegir una de las
variables para eliminarla y vamos a
eliminar la x por lo tanto lo que me
hace falta para eliminar la x es
convertir este 3x en 6x y para esto lo
que voy a hacer es multiplicar la
primera ecuación
por dos entonces déjame ponerlo de esta
manera si yo lo quiero resolver por suma
y resta entonces tengo que multiplicar
esta ecuación por dos y que voy a
obtener vamos a poner lo mejor aquí
abajo para que quede todo mucho más
claro voy a multiplicar por 2 bueno si
multiplico esta cuestión por 2 obtengo
6x menos 14 james esto es igual a 2 y
perfecto ya podemos eliminar la equis
porque la ecuación de arriba tenemos
menos 6x en la ecuación de abajo tenemos
6x y por lo tanto vamos a tomarlo 0 más
o + 0 esto es igual a cero es decir que
0 es igual a 0 y esto realmente no es
una atrocidad porque cero si es cero sin
embargo esto se le conoce como un
sistema de pendiente cuando llegamos a
soluciones del estilo 0 igual a cero
estamos hablando de un sistema
dependiente y qué quiere decir esto
bueno qué te parece si tomamos cada una
de estas ecuaciones y las ponemos en su
forma pendiente ordenada al origen para
graficar las rectas y ver y entender
mejor qué es lo que está pasando con un
sistema de pendiente ojo si tenemos un
punto de intersección es un sistema
consistente
si llegamos a algo medio bizarro de la
forma 0 igual a una constante estamos
hablando del sistema inconsistente pero
si llegamos a algo de la forma ser igual
a 0 estamos hablando de un sistema
dependiente entonces tomemos la primera
ecuación y vamos a despejar a james y me
queda que menos 7 bien es igual a menos
3x ya lo pasé del otro lado más 1 y
ahora voy a dividir todo entre menos 7 y
me queda que james es igual a menos
entre menos me da más a 3 séptimos de x
menos un séptima y es igual a 3 séptimos
de x menos un séptimo ahora tomemos la
segunda ecuación y la segunda ecuación
nos decía que menos 6x más 14 y que es
igual a menos 2 y de igual manera vamos
a despejar allí para esto voy a pasar
del otro lado este menos 6 x con signo
positivo y lo que me va a quedar es que
14 james es igual a 6 x menos 2 y
dividiendo todo entre 14 lo que da que
james es igual a 6 entre 14 x menos 2
entre 14 sin embargo estas fracciones
les puedo simplificar me queda que es lo
mismo que 3 séptimos de x menos un
séptimo y bueno aquí está ya escrita mi
segunda ecuación en su forma pendiente
ordenador
y ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta
y lo importante que tenemos que ver aquí
es que si nosotros gráfica mos estas dos
ecuaciones vamos a llegar a algo muy
curioso porque si yo me tomo mi primera
ecuación y la gráfico primero date
cuenta que tenemos una ordenada el
origen de menos un séptimo así que
tenemos una ecuación por aquí y después
si yo agarro la segunda ecuación y la
gráfico qué creés tenemos la misma
pendiente y tenemos la misma orden a dar
origen por lo tanto me estoy refiriendo
a la misma recta la gráfica de esta otra
ecuación es la misma recta que la
ecuación del principio y por lo tanto
tenemos muchos puntos que coinciden en
este de aquí este de aquí este de aquí
tenemos muchos puntos tantos como una
infinidad es decir que un sistema de
pendiente lo que nos dice es que tenemos
una infinidad de soluciones porque todos
los puntos son soluciones todos los
puntos de esta recta son solución porque
son la misma recta y de hecho por eso se
llaman dependientes y de hecho se llaman
ecuaciones dependientes porque podemos
obtener una ecuación con la otra si te
das cuenta podemos obtener la segunda
ecuación multiplicando la primera
- 2 para todas las xy todas las 10 que
estén en esta recta se cumple para el
punto 1 2 séptimos para el punto 0 - el
séptimo esto es lo que se llama un
sistema de pendiente y bueno ya que
tenemos la tercera opción así que déjame
hacerte un pequeño repaso de todos lo
que vimos en este vídeo nosotros tenemos
dos rectas y las rectas interceptan en
un solo punto estamos hablando de un
sistema consistente y tenemos solamente
una solución aquí están mis dos rectas y
su punto de intersección si tenemos algo
que es bastante loco como por ejemplo
aquí cero igual a menos 28 estamos
hablando del sistema inconsistente y son
dos rectas paralelas por lo tanto no
tenemos solución este era el segundo
caso recuerdas y el tercer caso es
cuando nosotros tenemos algo que es
obviamente cierto cero igual a cero y en
este caso tenemos un sistema de
pendiente lo que quiere decir que
tenemos una infinidad de soluciones
porque estamos hablando de la misma
recta así que espero que he encontrado
todo esto útil y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo